la radio et puis toutes les choses
graves j'ai l'impression qu'on les
apprend par la radio quand on écoute la
radio on sait si c'est grave ou si c'est
pas grave plus qu'à la tv
[Musique]
nouvelle manifestation contre le pass
vaccinale ce samedi à lille strasbourg
ou encore nice les opposants au
dispositif se sont retrouvées dans
plusieurs villes de france à paris les
nouvelles mesures sanitaires en vigueur
depuis lundi était la cible de plusieurs
cortèges et gilet jaune ou encore les
patriotes de florian philippot un autre
rassemblement a pris la direction du
siège de fans de pfizer
[Musique]
restez fermes avec la russie sans semer
la panique l'appel de l'ukraine aux
occidentaux ce samedi un équilibre
précaire alors que washington annonce
l'envoi de soldats en europe de l'est
tout comme paris qui postera les siens
en roumanie son côté moscou assure ne
pas vouloir de guerre et préférer la
voie diplomatique
au yémen le conflit pas son plein la
brigade des géants reste prête à
repousser les outils sept milices pro
gouvernementales soutenues par les
émirats arabes unis occupent des
positions défensives à proximité de la
ville de marib après avoir libéré
plusieurs districts stratégique elle
appelle le gouvernement à terminer
l'offensive face aux rebelles
[Musique]
et
bonsoir et bienvenue pour une nouvelle
page d'actualité
depuis lundi un test négatif ne suffit
plus pour accéder à de nombreux lieux de
vie il faut être vaccinés contre le coc
vidé et présenter son pass vaccinale un
dispositif synonyme de privation de
liberté pour de nombreux français et
plusieurs mobilisation était organisée
ce jour à nice lille strasbourg ou
encore paris où les partisans de florian
philippot étaient rassemblés au
trocadéro une autre marche s'est dirigée
elle vers le siège du laboratoire pfizer
enfin à l'appel des gilet jaune
plusieurs cortèges se sont tenus dans la
capitale et notre reporter nadège
abderrazak y était
manifestation qui s'est déroulée dans le
calme et la bonne humeur excepté au
moment où le cortège s'est approché de
la pitié salpêtrière c'est en effet dans
cet hôpital qui est hospitalisé en mai
chez ben farhat se déclarant historique
des manifestations de gilet jaune a été
victime d'un grave accident de la route
en début de semaine les gilet jaune
avait donc à coeur de lui manifester
leur soutien devant l'entrée du bâtiment
qui c'était impossible refusée par les
autorités s'en est suivi quelques
tensions et une grosse colère de faouzi
lellouche les forces de l'ordre n'ont
pas hésité à faire usage de spray au
poivre pour faire reculer l est
manifestants et à ozil est louche qui
était donc en tête de cortège mettez gaz
et gratuitement va traquer et opprimés
parce que tout simplement ils voulaient
pas qu'on aille voilà
rendre hommage à des jets qui à nos
camarades du milieu depuis trois ans qui
suivent la création d'une opération qui
avait un accident a donc tout simplement
c'est une affaire de 20 mètres donc du
coup la tension est montée franchement
soutien à camara qui pourrait comprendre
et au lieu de ça bien c'est des cases et
à bout portant visé volontairement et ce
qui crée une tension donc on a pu voir
des forces de l'ordre avec une
disproportion vraiment de force autre
figure du mouvement présent au sein de
ce cortège aujourd'hui et jérôme
rodriguez qui s'est lui aussi montré les
très en colère contre l'action du
gouvernement et le mandat est d'emmanuel
macron à la tête du pays aujourd'hui je
le répète il ya un mécontentement qui
s'installe en france beaucoup de gens
tombent sur le marché de la précarité
qui n'est pas du coq au vide dû aussi à
la hausse des prix et de tout ce que
peuvent subir les français au delà des
lois liberticides
aujourd'hui tu as une majorité de deux
français dont 7 millions de français qui
ont tenu bon face à toutes les
saloperies qu'on a pu le remettre dans
la tronche les insultes enfin si tu veux
si aujourd'hui ferait disparaître de la
rue il n'en tient qu'à macron parce que
c'est lui qui est générateur aujourd'hui
de ce mécontentement à chaque fois qu'il
prend la parole c'est pour te donner un
ordre d'idée je prends 20 mille abonnés
sur ma page tu vois donc si un moment et
c'est lui le problème alors soit le
problème il leur règle en ayant un peu
plus de respect vis-à-vis de sa
population vis-à-vis de son peuple soit
disant l'a élu légitimement soit un
moment donné la contestation continuera
on est vraiment la seule force
d'opposition aujourd'hui de
mécontentement quand tu vois ce qui se
passe dans l'assemblée où tout le monde
vote le doigt levé sur la couture pour
ne serait-ce que accomplir la la la le
sombre dessein de notre président on est
obligé d'être dans la rue aujourd'hui on
est obligé manifestation pour protester
une fois encore contre la hausse des
prix de l'énergie du carburant et de
certaines matières l'occasion aussi de
protester contre eux le pass vaccinale
entrée en vigueur cette semaine alors
que d'autres pays comme le royaume-uni
le danemark ou encore l'espagne ont
allégé de manière significative leurs
restrictions sanitaires ou moins chez
les jeunes c'est un mouvement citoyen
citoyen en colère qui est très très
important pour se battre pour les droits
du peuple c'est vraiment essentiel on
avait déjà les bases qui me porte le
mouvement gilet jaune justice sociale de
justice fiscale meilleure égalité entre
les citoyens et les jo de les élites qui
sont malheureusement privilégié depuis
bien trop longtemps mais aujourd'hui un
combat essentiel qui est rentré en plus
depuis cet été et depuis toutes ces
mesures qui est contre la vaccination
obligatoire contre le passeport qui
était sanitaire qui est devenu vaccinale
et là c'est la liberté de tous les
citoyens qui est attaqué l'espoir c'est
en montrant quand même qu'on est là tous
les samedis dans la rue montrer aux gens
qu'il ya quand même une résistance à ça
que s'ils sont tous seuls dans leur coin
pas forcément dans la rue sont pas tout
seul à penser la même chose parce qu'on
est quand même on est peut on est peu
nombreux dans la rue mais on est très
nombreux à penser la même chose quand
même
même des gens qui sont fait vacciner et
qui se soumettent à l'obligation
vaccinale sont pas forcément pour cela
fait plus de trois ans que les jets les
jeunes crient leur colère on pourrait
penser qu'ils attendent élections
présidentielles avec l'espoir ce n'est
pas le cas puisqu'il estime que
l'ensemble de la classe politique est
corrompu malgré tout ils annoncent
qu'ils continueront à faire entendre
leur voix chaque samedi
et notre éditorialiste michel fize
analyse ce contexte regardez
ce mouvement il continue son chemin il a
connu des hauts et des bas mais ils
expriment évidemment une société qui
quoi qu'on dise va mal en fin de compte
dans cette société tout va mal notre
école va mal notre régime politique va
mal notre économie ne va pas si bien que
ça et je crois qu'il est important
effectivement de montrer qu'il ya
toujours une france qui souffre une
france qui a du mal j'avais même dire a
commencé les débuts de mois parce que le
problème n'est plus la fin de mois un
parfois au début du mois on est déjà
endetté on ne sait plus comment comment
comment comment faire voilà donc je
crois que au delà des grands messages de
réassurance eh bien on a une situation
qui est inchangé depuis maintenant cinq
ans retour sur le rassemblement du
mouvement de florian philippot le
cortège du candidat des patriotes a
démarré dans l'après midi depuis la
place du trocadéro au vert le ministère
de la santé flipo la france reste en
retard sur ce qui est payant qui lève
les restrictions saison commencée ils
vont me demande si à la fin il n'en sera
plus que le seul pays au monde à mettre
en place ses réflexions et ses passes
pas tous les pays sont en train de
supprimer tout ça ce matin on apprend
que c'est l'islande hier la catalogne
l'angleterre l'espagne le
l'irlande
danemark la suède va tout le monde est
en train d'arrêter tout ça ça n'a
absolument aucun sens ça donne une
chance alors encore moins avec le micro
et il faut revenir à une vie totalement
normal donc évidemment qu'on se bat mais
voyez que le gouvernement va dans le
sens inverse puisqu'il vient d'annoncer
le certificat de rétablissement
n'était plus valable que quatre mois au
lieu de six mois quand vous avez une
infection ce qui fait qu'ils veulent
absolument vendre des doses de vaccin à
tout prix donc ils sont simplement des
vrp des grands laboratoires ils ne sont
pas ministres ils ne sont pas présents
rappeler qu'ils sont juste des vrp de
grands laboratoires pharmaceutiques l'
affaire a fait grand bruit et finalement
le projet de déplacer les consommateurs
de crack du nord-est de paris est
abandonnée pourtant les associations de
riverains ont tenu à se réunir en
soutien aux habitants du 19e
arrondissement et pour protester contre
la gestion du dossier par la ville mardi
le préfet de paris avait annoncé le
départ des 150 à 200 consommateurs de
crack situé porte de la villette vers le
quartier de bercy avant de faire volte
face devant l'opposition de la mairie
depuis les deux parties se renvoient la
responsabilité une situation qui
exaspère les habitants
en fait si vous voulez on est on est
pris en otage entre là dans la passe
d'armes entre la mairie centrale anne
hidalgo et la préfecture de police de
paris on est au milieu et ils se
renvoient la balle chacun donc nous nous
refusons d'être victimes de
de leurs bonnes actions leur mauvaise de
leur mauvaise gestion de la situation et
nous demandons à ce que la situation
soit pris au sérieux dès maintenant que
tout cela cesse et que ce soit dans le
19ème dans le 18e 20e 12e ou ailleurs il
revendique ni dans le nord-est de paris
que cesse cette errance de toxicomanes
qui sont dangereux et pour eux et promet
je suis ravi de
de cette annulation néanmoins sa taissy
mois que le lit de bercy est évoqué donc
c'est pas nouveau il ya quelques mois ça
devait être dans une école
avoir une salle de senteurs dans une
école à côté d'une école dans le 20e
arrondissement
donc il faut vraiment que la maire de
paris enfin plein de ses responsabilités
des seize
rejeter la faute les uns sur les autres
être responsable c'est se met derrière
une haie derrière une table avec tous
les acteurs avec la préfecture et enfin
de trouver un plan mais un plan
opérationnel contre le crack à paris
l'actualité politique à présent avec
yannick jadot le candidat écologiste
veut en finir avec le blabla de l'acte
de l'inaction climatique
en meeting à lyon devant 300 personnes
il a décliné son programme pour
instaurer une république écologique avec
quelques mesures phares parmi 120
propositions l'arrêt de dix réacteurs
nucléaires d'ici 2035 le déploiement de
6000 nouvelles éoliennes un isf
climatique ou encore la construction de
700 mille logements sociaux de nombreux
élus écologistes étaient présents pour
écouter leur dis de
2022 l'année où tout doit changer
l'année où tout peut changer
alors changé
changeons c'est le slogan pour mobiliser
toute la société
tous les secteurs économiques et toutes
les énergies
changeons c'est l'appel de la jeunesse à
celles et ceux qui détruisent leur
avenir
changeons c'est le mot d'ordre de toutes
celles et ceux qui veulent mener la
bataille dépolluer face aux pollueurs
changeons mes amis ce n'est pas
seulement un slogan c'est une alerte les
climato cyniques manoeuvres en coulisses
vous le savez pour préserver leurs
intérêts économiques et financiers
il actionne les lobbystes à paris à
bruxelles et dans le monde entier nous
les empêcheront de nuire à l'action
publique
la candidate rassemblement national est
elle à madrid marine le pen ya retrouvé
les principales figures européennes de
la droite souverainiste dont le premier
ministre hongrois viktor orban dont son
homologue polonais un voyage pour mettre
de côté les défections dans ses rangs la
semaine passée l'avocat gilbert collard
a décidé de rejoindre le candidat eric
zemmour est désormais la nièce de la
candidate marion maréchal fait planer le
doute un éventuel ralliement qui serait
synonyme de coup dur pour marine le pen
alors que l'eurodéputé nicolas bay lui
aussi reste flou sur ses intentions la
candidate et rennes a ainsi appelé ceux
qui veulent la quitter à le faire
maintenant
présidentielle toujours avec le
déplacement de valérie pécresse dans
l'ain un territoire où un habitant sur
quatre n'aurait pas de médecin
généraliste
hier à oyonnax la candidate des
républicains en a profité pour dévoiler
ses priorités en matière de santé
le récit de samira schalit
remettre de l'ordre voilà le maître mot
de valérie pécresse à oyonnax près de 22
mille quatre cents habitants c'est là
que la candidate les républicains à la
présidentielle a fait halte pour évoquer
sa politique de santé l'actuel président
du conseil régional d'ile-de-france a
visité une maternité de l'hôpital de la
commune avant d'échanger avec les
acteurs locaux de la santé un échange au
cours duquel elle a exposé ses grandes
mesures
une consultation de médecine générale à
25 euros compte tenu des prix du coût de
la vie aujourd'hui ce n'est pas digne ce
n'est pas digne parce que ça vaut
beaucoup plus une consultation donc moi
je pense qu'il faudra travailler sur une
nouvelle convention pour revoir le tarif
de 25 à 30 euros
mon projet c'est de créer 25 mille
postes de soignants à l'hôpital est de
doubler le nombre de médecins formés
pour les porter à 20 milles d'ici la fin
du quinquennat vingt mille admis en
deuxième année
trois grandes causes ont marqué son
propos la santé mentale les cancers
pédiatriques et la santé des femmes sur
ce sujet l'ex ministre de nicolas
sarkozy propose une baisse de la tva à
2,1 pour cent sur les protections
périodiques et la reconnaissance d'un
congé spécifique en cas de règles
douloureuses autres fers de lance de la
candidate la lutte contre les déserts
médicaux territoire oblige là dessus
elle propose une vaste réforme de
décentralisation du système de santé
celle ci doit permettre aux acteurs
locaux d'élaborer un plan de réduction
des délais et temps de trajet pour
accéder aux soins sans en dire plus la
ligne semble clair donc agir vite pour
la santé alors qu'un récent sondage
place celle ci en seconde position dans
la liste de préoccupations des français
d'après un sondage ipsos pour france
inter
un signal entendu par la candidate
valérie pécresse à oyonnax elle qui
espère donner du souffle à une
candidature qui marque le pas elle aura
à nouveau l'occasion de le faire pour
son premier grand meeting politique le
13 février prochain au zénith de paris
en italie le président sortant de 80 ans
sergio matériel à va être réélu les
partis de la coalition au pouvoir sont
tombés d'accord afin d'assurer la
stabilité politique le président ne
souhaitait pourtant pas continuer mais
il avait aussi dit se tenir à
disposition s'il était élu le 7e tour de
scrutin lui a attribué 400 voix le
huitième devrait bientôt livré son
verdict sans verdict par dont 505 voix
sont nécessaires pour désigner
définitivement matar est là dont le
poste de président est en italie
largement protocolaires mais c'est un
rôle important en cas de crise politique
la crise ukrainienne et la voie
diplomatique qui reste d'actualité même
si les occidentaux maintiennent la
pression sur moscou les etats unis
annoncent envoyé des soldats en europe
de l'est la france aussi on verra des
contingents en roumanie la russie elle
continue de la firme et elle ne menacera
aucune offensive en territoire ukrainien
le président ukrainien qui s'est
entretenu hier avec emmanuel macron
appelle les européens à ne pas semer la
panique
aujourd'hui nous n'assistons pas à une
escalade plus importante qu'auparavant
oui le nombre de militaires a augmenté
mais j'ai parlé de cela au début de
l'année 2000 21 quand ils ont parlé des
exercices militaires de la fédération de
russie
d'après la couverture médiatique des
événements on dirait que nous sommes
déjà en guerre que les troupes sont déjà
sur les routes qui lie à une
mobilisation avec des gens qui vont
quelque part ce n'est pas le cas nous
n'avons pas besoin de cette panique
avant son entretien téléphonique avec
hélène ski emmanuel macron et est en
ligne avec la dimerie poutine
une discussion de plus d'une heure
l'occasion pour le président russe de
faire part de son regret à la france que
les américains et l'otan n'est pas prise
en compte ses exigences mais aussi
l'occasion pour la russie la france de
plaider pour la poursuite et le respect
des accords de minsk
lors de la discussion sur la situation
en ukraine vladimir poutine a souligné
l'importance du strict respect par kiev
des dispositions du paquet de mesures de
minsk et d'autres accords principalement
sur l'établissement d'un dialogue direct
avec donetsk est lougansk ainsi que sur
la régularisation au niveau juridique du
statut spécial du dombass compte tenu
des résultats de la réunion des
conseillers politiques des dirigeants
des quatre pays du format normandie qui
s'est tenue à paris le 26 janvier la
volonté de poursuivre le travail commun
de la russie et de la france au sein de
ce format a été confirmée
c'est une manifestation redoutée par les
autorités canadiennes des dizaines de
milliers de camionneurs sont attendus ce
samedi à ottawa au nord du pays une
colère qui a pris une ampleur imprévue
en cause les dernières mesures
sanitaires qui concerne leur profession
dont l'obligation vaccinale ont fait le
point avec walid ben ali
on l'appelle déjà le convoi de la
liberté sur la route d'ottawa les klaxon
ont résonné sur plus de 70 km
le drapeau sortie fièrement tout comme
le mot freedom traduisait liberté
plusieurs camionneurs revendiquent leur
choix de se faire vacciner un sujet qui
cristallise les tensions
nous avons choix dans ce pays pas de
tyrannie on ne nous dit pas qu'on
injecte et dans notre corps c'est
ridicule nous devons être vaccinés vous
voulez faire des allers-retours à
travers les frontières vous voulez un
travail faites vous vacciner
selon l'une des plus importantes
fédérations de camionnage du pays 15%
soit seize mille chauffeur ne dispose
pas d'un schéma vaccinal complet depuis
le 15 janvier les autorités exigent une
vaccination obligatoire pour les
camionneurs canadiens souhaitant
traverser la frontière avec les états
unis afin d'éviter une quarantaine de 14
jours des protestations qui ne sont pas
du goût du premier ministre justin
trudeau estime que ces convois ne sont
pas représentatifs du point de vue des
canadiens la réalité c'est que presque
90% des camionneurs au canada sont
vaccinés comme presque 90 % de notre
population
les canadiens se préoccupent de leur
liberté de leurs droits et ils savent
que la meilleure façon de protéger leurs
droits et leurs libertés c'est d'en
finir avec cette pandémie
de son côté le ministre des transports a
fustigé la récupération politique de
certains élus de l'opposition qui
alimentent des rumeurs de pénurie liée à
ces manifestations le rassemblement
prévu dans la capitale samedi redouter
certains observateurs craignant
l'assimilation du mouvement à des
tendances plus radicale ces derniers
jours plusieurs associations et groupes
facebook ont appelé au calme craignant
que le mouvement dégénère sur le mode
l'assaut du capitole qui avait fait
trembler des états unis il ya non notre
priorité numéro un a toujours été et
continue d'être un rassemblement
pacifique pour faire entendre nos voix à
travers le canada soyez gentil soyez
respectueux soyez unifiée c'est une
action pacifique et légale ne vous mêlez
pas aux agitateurs dont nous savons
pertinemment qu'ils seront présents
les camionneurs qui ont encore gagné en
popularité après un soutien inattendu
celui du milliardaire elon musk pdg de
tesla qui les a encouragés sur twitter
un message aimé par près de quatre cent
mille personnes vendredi soir
la coalition militaire dirigée par
l'arabie saoudite et à laquelle
participent les émirats arabes unis
intervient depuis 2015 au yémen en
soutien au gouvernement contre les
outils une guerre qui a fait plus de 370
mille morts selon l'onu des décès causés
par les bombardements mais aussi par la
famine les maladies et les offensives
autour de la ville stratégique de marib
menées cette semaine se poursuivre la
coalition a d'ailleurs enregistré
plusieurs succès des ripostes en réponse
aux attaques des outils ces dernières
semaines contre abou dhabi capitale des
émirats françois tisci beach
des combattants de la brigade des géants
fêtent leur victoire contre les outils à
leur autour de la ligne de front
cette unité des forces spéciales
yéménite soutenue par les émirats arabes
unis annoncent avoir repris le district
de harib au sud de marib après deux
semaines de combats sanglants
marib province riche en pétrole mais
surtout derniers fiefs du pouvoir
yéménite dans le nord du pays dont les
rebelles tentent de s'emparer depuis
plusieurs mois
dieu merci la bataille a changé type et
nos forces ont passé de la défense à
l'attaqué
dieu merci c'est grâce à nos braves
combattants
une contre offensive menée par les
forces gouvernementales au lendemain
d'une nouvelle attaque outil contre les
émirats et l'arabie saoudite dans
laquelle deux personnes ont été blessées
le 17 janvier des frappes de drones et
de missiles avaient fait trois morts
abou dhabi la capitale émirati une
attaque meurtrière suivie par une série
de bombardements aériens de la coalition
et par des offensives au sol
vendredi dernier une frappe contre une
prison à saada fief des outils dans le
nord du pays a fait au moins 70 morts et
plus d'une centaine de blessés
la coalition en a nié toute
responsabilité
nous étions dans la prison et à 2 heures
du matin le vendredi l' agression
saoudienne nous a frappés avec la
première frappe aérienne nous étions
dans la halle de et tous mes amis qui
était près de moi ont été tués j'ai
survécu ainsi qu'une autre personne qui
était assise à côté de moi tous les
autres sont morts les outils ont menacé
de mener d'autres attaques contre les
émirats pays qui abritent des troupes
américaines sur son sol les etats unis
ont d'ailleurs recommandé ce mercredi à
leurs citoyens de reconsidérer tout
voyage à abou dhabi en raison de menaces
d'attaqués de drones ou de missiles
de son côté
l'organisation des nations unies s'est
dit alarmé par la spirale de violences
au yémen qui continue d'affecter les
civils et déborde au delà de ses
frontières
selon l'onu le conflit a fait au moins 3
177 mille morts et conduit une
population de 30 millions d'habitants au
bord d'une famine à grande échelle
qui composent la brigade des géants
éléments de réponse avec céline josy
analyste spécialiste du yémen qui était
tout à l'heure sur rt france
la brigade des géants en fait c'est une
brigade qui a été composée aux finances
et si on peut appeler ça par les
personnes qui restait de l'armée et
émérite mais qui sont en même temps
financer deux par les émirats arabes par
la commission mais particulièrement pas
lésiné à rapper sont assez proches de la
brigade si on peut appeler ça une
brigade qui est gérée par le le neveu de
l'ancien président aimé ni tata qui a
half hodeïda et c'est une brigade qui
est
vu par la coalition ou et où on essaie
de véhicules ex brigade qui essaie de
défendre
le gouvernement ait lieu et aussi les
intérêts des vrais intérêts des manic
toutefois c'est une brigade qui aussi et
des rumeurs ou les remarques qui ont été
faites à 7.4 c'est qu'elle a ramassé si
je fais appeler ça comme ça où elle est
constituée d'un certain nombre de
personnes qui participent et faisaient
partie des groupes qui étaient des
groupes assez j'irai pas al-qaïda mais
des coûts des troupes qui était qui
faisait partie des milices itx peut
appeler ça promet pour le moment c'est
une c'est une brigade qui essaie de se
montrer comme une régate qui défend les
intérêts de du gouvernement et de la
coalition
en ethiopie dans la province du tigré le
drame humanitaire se poursuit le
programme alimentaire mondial de l'onu
tire la sonnette d'alarmé 40% de la
population éthiopienne du tigre et
souffre d'une pénurie extrême de
nourriture cyrielle bout et
aux tigres et les rations s'amenuisent
jour après jour depuis plusieurs mois
cette région de l'ethiopie est plongé
dans une véritable catastrophe
humanitaire qui vient s'ajouter au fléau
de la guerre civile lors d'un communiqué
ce vendredi le programme alimentaire
mondial a révélé des chiffres alarmants
parmi la population du tigre et deux
millions se trouvent en grave insécurité
alimentaire soit près de 40% de la
population
en avant le programme alimentaire
mondial estime qu'en moyenne les
familles touchées par la crise dans le
nord de l'ethiopie ont reçu moins de 30%
de leurs besoins caloriques au cours des
derniers mois ce qui a aggravé la crise
l'ex-pro s'attend à ce qu'une aide
alimentaire humanitaire constante soit
nécessaire au moins tout au long de
l'année 2022 clisters twenty twente et
eu une famille particulièrement accrue
depuis quelques semaines en cause
notamment une grave pénurie de carburant
qui empêche les convois humanitaires
d'accéder à la région du tigré depuis le
24 janvier dernier le peu
d'approvisionnement s'effectue à pied
dans le tigre et les nations unies nos
ong partenaires ont été contraintes de
réduire leurs opérations en raison des
graves pénuries de fourniture de
carburant et d'argent les organisations
ont prévenu que les opérations pourrait
cesser complètement d'ici la fin du mois
de février
des opérations qui subissent la pression
de la reprise des combats dans la région
de l'afar à bas la ville charnière pour
l'approvisionnement du tigré puisqu'elle
se situe sur le principal axe utilisé
par l'aide humanitaire le porte parole
du front de libération du peuple du
tigré accusent le gouvernement éthiopien
de se servir du conflit pour renforcer
le blocus humanitaire un convoi de 27
camions a apparemment quitté ses meira
en direction de tigre et le convoi était
censé débloquer l'accès humanitaire aux
tigres et du moins c'est ce qu'on nous a
dit il s'est avéré qu alors que le
gouvernement d'addis abeba avait
ostensiblement donné son feu vert le
gouvernement régional d'afar n'était pas
d'accord l'excusé donnée était que le
gouvernement régional n'approuvait pas
le convoi et qu'il y avait des combats à
bâle à une reprise des combats qui ne
semble pourtant pas alarmer le
gouvernement ce mercredi le premier
ministre éthiopien habib ahmed a pris la
décision de lever l'état d'urgence en
ethiopie qui avait été décrété en
novembre dans tout le pays et pour une
durée de six mois et si la fin de cette
édition merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
point sur l'actualité dans une trentaine
de minutes
[Musique]
l'actualité économique de la semaine
décryptées par olivier delamarche le rsa
remplit-il ses objectifs non à en croire
un rapport de la cour des comptes
comment voulez-vous avec un peu plus de
500 euros vous en tirez et vous loger et
c'est donc évidemment que c'est pas un
tremplin pour quoi que ce soir je pense
que le dispositif aura et une efficacité
si on est dans une économie réellement
solidaire pour à l'édition 2022 choose
france 21 projets d'investissements ont
été annoncées en france il ya une
contrepartie qu'on va promettre à des
entreprises si elles viennent
s'implanter que d'abord on les embêtera
pas trop sur les licenciements qu'ils
annonceront après et vous aurez une une
déduction fiscale ou d